[Music]
he's harder to cancel than a
subscription to that website your wife
knows nothing about
he'll bring down the house and then i'll
help you remodel it he also won a sexual
health and entertainment award in the
year 2000 and it's all been downhill
since
joining me now radio personality
comedian actor and host of the adam
corolla show and dare i say a living
legend adam carolla
adam i always think you get short shrift
i don't know if that's the word in terms
of creating the podcast world
weren't you basically the first person
to figure out how to cancel proof
yourself like you went off and did your
own thing you're your own boss you could
say whatever you want
yeah it was funny i had somebody say to
me
recently they said
did you know this was all coming when
you started your podcast 13 years ago
and i said no i didn't see any of this
coming and then i paused and i said well
maybe i did
because that's how i acted
and i guess i did you know like an
indian who puts his ear to the ground
and feels something bad this way cometh
i felt that way about our society about
the way they were going to approach free
speech and comedians and i guess i did
try to become sort of autonomous
early on knowing this was coming so this
is the difference between me and you you
can use the analogy of the indian with
his ear to the ground but if i do it i'm
gonna get fired
well maybe he was an eastern indian kid
and there is no stereotype there you go
there you go
do you um have you ever been nervous
have you ever been nervous about uh
being canceled you know it's funny
because now we're living in a time where
it feels like cancer culture is being
overtold but it's only because the
reaction to it is is basically the same
strength as the threat did you ever feel
like you were threatened
no i've always
worked and you know i was a carpenter
long before i was a comedian and i i
learned from being a carpenter that if
you were good
and you were prompt and you didn't gouge
except the elderly i always gouge you
elderly
they don't have that much time on the
planet what do they need me and jesus we
both doubt she elderly the point is this
you would work if you were good you
would never stop working i never
advertised i never put leaflets on
windshields i never bought you know
spots on basic cable i was just a good
carpenter and i worked and i always kind
of took that approach to comedy be on
time
show up be funny gouge the elderly and
you will work in hollywood
now
in this as this world has changed do you
find yourself
i don't know losing any kind of friends
or you still have the same friends you
have uh that have been going on 20 years
i don't i don't see you as an active
conservative i always see you as
somebody who's maintained kind of the
same
tone in attitude as the world has
changed around you
do you find yourself increasingly
isolated or do you still get along with
the people you get along with
well i'll put it to you this way gutfeld
people think i entered this van just to
do a hit on your show i live in this van
there's a hot plate that's just
off camera
once in a while i'll bring a lady friend
in but generally i'm so isolated i'm in
this van no look the true friends the
real friends i have real friends in
hollywood and then there's your
hollywood friends your hollywood friends
don't tolerate
any deviation from their pattern or
their playlist or their dance card so
meaning
i can talk to alec baldwin on my podcast
and i can also talk to dinesh d'souza on
my podcast and that's the way i'd like
it but there's certain groups that won't
tolerate me talking to dinesh d'souza so
they will cut bait with me by the way
these are the same hypocritical
bloviated blowhards who never stop
railing against mccarthyism right this a
town that never stops talking about the
evils of mccarthyism who will gladly
blackball
you
and remove you from your source of
revenue if they could i had two things
uh one just comment i want to ask you
about your new gig you seem remarkably
calm
in any kind of time i listen to your
podcast all the time you never get upset
which i always find really kind of
admirable in the in in the in the
environment that you're in but you have
a new thing now on the daily wire that's
uh ben shapiro's great operation what is
it
it's called truth yeller and it's a
series of six stand-up specials
uh once again
i sort of naively thought a few years
ago i would just shoot a stand-up
special and sell it to netflix or sell
it to hbo or shel sell it to one of the
sort of legacy media companies they have
no interest in people like me and what i
have to say
so uh i needed to go somewhere and find
a platform and i ran into the daily wire
and i just dipped my chocolate into
their peanut butter
and
the rest is history i'm so glad you said
peanut butter
adam you're awesome
congrats and i'm going to keep listening
to you as long as you do work i'm going
to be i'm going to be a
a happy customer so thanks for coming on
thanks greg appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else